David Boder: [In English] Now, will you speak in English? And if you can’t, you speak in French. All right. I will ask you the questions in English and you can answer them. [aside] All right. I am here at the home of Admiral Kahn, in the presence of three generations. There’s the grandfather, the father of Mrs. Kahn, who spoke to us before, and the Admiral, his wife and here now with me on the sofa is his young son. Now tell me, what’s your name?
Jean Kahn: Jean.
David Boder: Your name is John. John what?
Jean Kahn: Jean Kahn.
David Boder: John Kahn. And how old are you, John?
Jean Kahn: I am fifteen now.
David Boder: You are fifteen.
Jean Kahn: Yes.
David Boder: Now, that’s nice English. And any time you are look for words, just speak French. You are now fifteen. And how old were you when the war started?
Jean Kahn: It was in 1940.
David Boder: So how old were you?
Jean Kahn: I was ten.
David Boder: You were ten, yes. Now, start talking French. And tell me what do you remember about the start of the war. Go ahead in French.
Jean Kahn: [In French] Eh bien, tout d’abord j’ai vu beaucoup de monde courir dans les rues, allant à l’encontre des nouvelles, car à la radio beaucoup de speakers, ne sachant pas eux-mêmes les nouvelles, avaient livré la radio à des spectacles de musique et de chansons. Et la première chose que je vis le matin en m’éveillant, ce sont des cars de troupes qui montaient au front par le Nord à l’approchée de Sedan...et tout le monde était affolé, entourant la radio.
David Boder: [In English] Now tell me. What month was it? Were you in school then? What month was it when the war started?
Marcelle Kahn: [In French] [Interpreter intervenes] Quel mois c’était?
David Boder: [In English] Do you remember?
Jean Kahn: [In French] C’était en juin. En juin.
David Boder: [In English] Were you in school then?
Jean Kahn: [In French] Oui, j’étais en classe, au lycée de Lorient.
David Boder: [In English] And what did you think about the war? What did you think it would be? Did you like it?
Jean Kahn: [In French] Je ne pensais pas que cela durerait très longtemps.
David Boder: [In English] Uh huh. Now, tell me what then happened?
Jean Kahn: [In French] Eh bien, nous avons été obligés de nous enfuir devant les Allemands qui avaient réussi à faire une percée dans l’Est et à ce temps-là, nous ne pensions pas qu’ils allaient avancer rapidement. Et alors, dès le 18 juin 1940, nous avons été forcés de parcourir la France du Nord au Sud et de l’orient d’arriver à Marseille.
David Boder: [In English] Bon. Who was with you in Marseille?
Jean Kahn: My grandfather, my mother and my brother.
David Boder: And where was your father?
Jean Kahn: He was at the war.
David Boder: Your father was in the war. All right. Now, what happened then in Marseille? Speak French.
Jean Kahn: [In French] [conversation with interpreter] C’est à Marseille que j’ai appris que l’armistice avait été signé.
David Boder: [In English] All right. And where did you go from Marseille? Tell me. [aside to someone else: “It was a great pleasure and thank you very much.”]
Jean Kahn: [In French] [conversation with interpreter] A Marseille, c’était en décembre 1942, nous avons entendu un message à la radio de Londres, message qui avait été convenu avec mon père à son départ: le canari est bien arrivé et il attend ses petits. C’était le signal que nous attendions pour partir pour aller le rejoindre. En octobre 1943, nous avons pris le train pour Perpignan, et c’est de là que nous passions faire toutes nos recherches et prévoir tous les embarras que nous aurions en traversant la frontière. Et de la fin d’octobre 1943 nous avons pris le train, sans les papiers qu’il fallait pour traverser la zone interdite, longeant la frontière espagnole. Et...mon frère et moi avons cherché le passage dans différents petits villages qui se trouvaient sur des sommets.
David Boder: Et votre mère?
David Boder: [In English] And where was your mother?
Jean Kahn: [In French] Et ma mère attendait à Perpignan les résultats de notre enquête...Pour les enfants, il ne fallait pas de papiers spéciaux pour entrer dans la zone interdite. Et nous avions tous les deux moins de dix-sept ans à ce moment-là et nous pouvions passer assez facilement à travers les haies de police allemande qui contrôlaient les papiers des autres personnes. Voyant que tout était impossible devant le refus de tout le monde de nous aider, mêmes des guides qui avaient été questionnés, sans idées totalement de voir seulement ce que nous pourrions faire, nous sommes retournés à Perpignan décidés à partir seuls, sans guide, avec l’aide de personne. Mon frère acheta une boussole et une carte d’état-major de la région, et vers midi, nous sommes partis de Perpignan, pour une petite ville qui s’appelle Osséja, située à combien d’altitude? située à 1200 mètres d’altitude. Nous n’avions évidemment réussi à avoir aucun papier permettant le passage de la zone interdite, et cependant, dans le village d’Osséja, nous étions déjà dans la zone interdite. Par conséquent, à tout contrôle, les Allemands auraient pu découvrir que nous n’avions pas de papiers et nous empêcher d’aller plus loin. Ceci ne s’est pas passé heureusement, mais à la sortie de la gare d’Osséja, nous avons remarqué qu’il y avait deux agents allemands qui demandaient les papiers permettant l’entrée en zone interdite. Nous sommes restés quelques instants sur la voie, et lorsque nous avons vu les deux agents partir, nous avons franchi la gare, et nous sommes sortis. Nous avions laissé deux sacs de montagne assez lourds et une valise à la consigne en vue de pouvoir plus librement faire nos recherches, nos dernières recherches et explorations du pays.
David Boder: Et puis?
Jean Kahn: Et puis nous sommes partis d’après...en suivant un trajet qui nous avait été vaguement indiqué par quelques personnes dans le petit village même. L’ascension commença vers la fin de l’après-midi, et la pluie tombait en faisant des mottes de gadoue. Nous étions enfoncés dans la boue, traînants, glissants, nous n’en pouvions plus et n’avancions pas. [Question off mic from interpreter] On n’osait pas sortir la carte d’état-major de peur de la tremper et de la perdre. De temps en temps nous regardions la boussole pour voir si nous étions dans la bonne direction, et nous entendions les chiens des policiers allemands. Nous ne savions pas s’ils étaient à nos trousses ou aux trousses de quelqu’un d’autre, mais on se taisait pour nous faire rater. Mon frère cependant nous exhortait et nous poussait comme il pouvait, car nous étions les deux plus fatigués, ma mère et moi. Et enfin, c’est lui qui remontait le moral du trio, et qui nous a toujours tenus dans la bonne voie avec sa boussole. A la sortie du village, nous avons vu une caserne allemande, qui...dans laquelle logeaient des douaniers, et nous avions vu un de leurs gros chiens policiers qui servent à dépister les gens qui essayent de passer la frontière. Enfin, après avoir marché pendant environ 5 heures, nous sommes tombés à pic sur une voie de chemin de fer au fond d’une vallée et nous avons aperçu une petite gare très semblable à nos gares françaises, et nous nous demandions si nous étions déjà en Espagne et non pas toujours en France. Il commençait à faire nuit, et nous n’osions pas nous découvrir et aller demander des renseignements, même approcher de la gare. En descendant, nous sommes tombés...comment s’appelle? un remblai...sur un remblai et nous avons été obligés de passer au dessous d’un tunnel, de contourner la voie et nous sommes descendus enfin sur une route qui semblait une route d’assez grande importance, malgré qu’il n’y ait pas beaucoup de circulation dessus. Enfin nous nous sommes approchés de la gare, et nous avons vu une inscription qui semblait bien ne pas être française. C’était [Filbas?], équivalent de [biffure?] en espagnol. Et puis peu à peu nous nous approchions sans nous en douter de la gare et nous avons entendu des jeunes filles chanter. Elles ne chantaient pas en français, mais en espagnol. Aussitôt, nous nous sommes approchés. Elles sont montées peut-être un peu effrayées chercher leur père. Leur père a tout de suite compris. Beaucoup de gens nous ont aidé, nous ont essuyé les pieds, nous ont donné à manger dans cette petite gare. Et le lendemain matin - ils nous avaient évidemment donné leurs lits pour passer la nuit—le lendemain matin, nous sommes partis de très bonne heure pour gagner la province de Barcelone, qui nous avait-on dit était moins dangereuse, et de là, on ne pouvait pas nous renvoyer en France. De l’aube même, nous avons marché certainement toute la matinée, et une bonne partie de l’après-midi, et nous allions prendre un car dans un petit village situé encore dans la montagne, lorsque nous avons vu deux carabineros habillés d’uniformes kaki et entourés de ceintures jaunes, avec de bas chapeaux [? de cire]. Ils sont venus vers nous, nous demander les papiers d’identité, documentation, et nous n’avons évidemment rien pu fournir. Ils nous ont fait monter dans un hôtel qui avait été réquisitionné entièrement par eux, et là a commencé l’interrogatoire, ainsi que la fouille. L’interrogatoire s’est prolongé toute l’après-midi. Ils posaient de temps en temps une question, nous ont présenté quelques fiches, nous ont confisqués tout ce que nous avions. On ramassait une part ou tout des choses qui étaient restées dans nos poches, et que nous avions essayé en vain de cacher. Et enfin, le soir, on nous a apporté un dîner très copieux, avec...pour la somme modique de 25.000 francs qui avaient été confisqués pendant l’interrogatoire. La nuit, ils nous ont fait passer dans une chambre dont les fenêtres avaient été grillagées, et avant de se coucher, ils nous ont enlevé nos chaussures.
David Boder: [In English] Were you all together?
Jean Kahn: Yes, we were all together in the room.
Jean Kahn: [In French] Et alors, ils ont enlevé nos chaussures, et le lendemain matin, ils ont frappé, ils nous ont réveillés, et ont de nouveau procédé à un interrogatoire plus détaillé.
David Boder: [aside, unintelligible]
Jean Kahn: Le surlendemain, nous avons été sortis de cette chambre et emmenés à Barcelone au quartier général de la police espagnole. Nous sommes restés là pas même cinq minutes. Nous avons été ramenés au poste de police, puis de nouveau à l’hôtel où nous avions passé les deux nuits précédentes, et enfin, deux carabineros nous ont emmenés en prison à Barcelone. Là, bref interrogatoire, et puis nous avons été jetés en prison, un peu comme des bêtes, dans de grandes cages dans les sous-sols de la préfecture de Barcelone. Le surlendemain, nous sommes sortis miraculeusement et avons réussi à faire partie d’un convoi qui devait gagner l’Afrique du nord, et nous mener enfin en terre libre. Nous avons atteint Casablanca au bout de deux jours et enfin nous avons su sur le bateau qui nous menait à Casablanca que mon père était à Alger. Et alors, au bout d’une semaine, passé des difficultés de transport entre Casablanca et Alger, nous avons rejoint mon père.
David Boder: [In English] Well, were you afraid during this whole trip?
Jean Kahn: A little bit, yes, but I really didn’t know the danger we could...
David Boder: that you were in.
Jean Kahn: Yes.
David Boder: You didn’t know the danger.
David Boder: What were you afraid of?
Jean Kahn: Of being arrested by the Germans, in the mountains.
David Boder: Yes. What month were you in the mountains? What month was it?
Jean Kahn: October.
David Boder: Was it cold in the mountains?
Jean Kahn: Not really cold, but the rain...
David Boder: It was raining.
Jean Kahn: Yes.
David Boder: Did you have good clothes?
Jean Kahn: No, we didn’t have good clothes. Only very bad shoes.
David Boder: Yes.
Jean Kahn: [In French] Et des vêtements décousus, des chaussettes déchirées par les ronces et trempées dans la boue. Et pour toute nourriture, nous n’avions qu’un kilo de sucre, qui fondait dans nos poches, et une gourde de rhum.
David Boder: [In English] Oh, did you drink rum?
Jean Kahn: No, I didn’t drink rum. Only with a piece of sugar.
David Boder: [laughing] Now, where did you get from Spain then? From Spain you came where?
Jean Kahn: In North Africa.
David Boder: To North Africa. All right. And when did you see your father again?
Jean Kahn: Just a month after our departure.
David Boder: From Marseille.
Jean Kahn: From Perpignan, from France.
David Boder: Just a month after your departure from Perpignan, you saw your father.
Jean Kahn: Yes.
David Boder: Well, did he look well?
Jean Kahn: Yes, just a little bit tired.
David Boder: Well, and then what were you doing in Africa?
Jean Kahn: I went to school there with all the little Arabs.
David Boder: Little Arabs.
Jean Kahn: Yes.
David Boder: And did you learn French or Arabian? What did you learn?
Jean Kahn: I learned French, yes.
David Boder: You studied in French.
Jean Kahn: Yes.
David Boder: All right. And are you now in school?
David Boder: In what grade are you?
Jean Kahn: I’m in the second degree.
David Boder: Is that the lycée?
Jean Kahn: Lycée, yes.
David Boder: So how many years do you need to be through?
Jean Kahn: [In French] Quatre ans?
Jean Kahn: [In English] Three years.
David Boder: Three years more, and then you will be...
Jean Kahn: Three years of lycée.
David Boder: Yes. And what will you do after that? What do you want to study?
Jean Kahn: I don’t know.
David Boder: You don’t know. Well, that is good. You are young. Do you want to be an Admiral?
Jean Kahn: No.
David Boder: No? [laughing] You don’t want to go to sea? Well, and now, do you feel good at school? Do you have a lot of friends?
Jean Kahn: Yes. A lot of friends. I had a lot of friends in England.
David Boder: Oh? Where were you in England?
Jean Kahn: At the French Lycée of London.
David Boder: At the French Lycée of London. Well, uh huh. Did you speak there more French or did you speak English there?
Jean Kahn: I spoke much French.
David Boder: Yes.
Jean Kahn: And some English in the evening.
David Boder: What subjects are you taking in school? Are you taking Latin?
Jean Kahn: Latin.
David Boder: Yes.
Jean Kahn: And math.
David Boder: Mathematics.
Jean Kahn: Mathematics.
David Boder: What do you have in mathematics now? [aside to interpreter] Algebra, geometry?
Jean Kahn: [In French] Géométrie et algèbre.
David Boder: [In English] Uh huh. And you take French literature?
Jean Kahn: French literature, history, geography, physics.
David Boder: Physics.
Jean Kahn: Chemistry.
David Boder: Do you have much to study when you go to school?
Jean Kahn: Yes, I have much. Too much!
David Boder: Too much. Well, John, you are an awfully good boy, and it was really a pleasure to have met you. And I think you told us a good story. And I think the children there, if we translate it, will have a lot of fun in listening to your story. We will translate it into English and have another little boy read it for us, make a record. Will you write to me sometimes?
Jean Kahn: Yes. Certainly.
David Boder: All right. I’ll write you a letter, then you will know my address. And then if I can, we make another wire and we send you one and then when you have a machine, then you can listen to it.
Jean Kahn: Thank you.
David Boder: Well, it was awfully good...[ends abruptly]